in the past nine months i've had to make
a number of decisions that had a
nine-figure ramification on my personal
net worth and what i want to walk you
through is the actual decision-making
framework or process that i used to
create those
and so if you're new to the channel my
name is doctor mosey i own
acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies that does about 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you all
right i make these videos because a lot
of people broke and i don't want you
going on all right so one of the
important i mean the most important
things that we have in our lives are our
decisions right and one of the things
that i live by is that we're one
decision away from changing our life
forever right you're one decision away
from drinking and getting killed in a
car car accident you're one decision
away from you know cheating on your
spouse and destroying your marriage you
know you're one one terrible comment
away from destroying your child right
and you're also one decision away from
destroying your business if you so chose
so decisions are the wellspring of life
or at least the the train track uh
splits uh of where we're going to end up
all right learning to make the decisions
is an important concept but believe it
or not for this video what i want to
focus on is actually the environment
under which to make the decision during
this process one of the things that was
very frustrating for me um and this
decision took me about 12 months to make
and i'll make i'll explain what the
decision wasn't in another video in the
future but it's safe to say like it was
it was a hugely impactful decision in my
life financially and otherwise one of
the difficulties that i was having is
that the information that i had was not
changing and yet my decision of which
way to go continue to falter all right
so i kept ping-ponging back and forth
and back and forth and back and forth
and so i was like
it's not my decision-making
process
right and the data that i have to make
this decision is unchanging and yet
at different days i would have different
outcomes which to me is big red flag
danger alert in terms of like the the um
a leading indicator of a bad decision
mind you as a quick caveat to this this
is not how you need to make all the
decisions in your life i would say that
you should find and use this process for
the most important decisions you make in
your life who are you going to marry
where are you going to live what are you
going to work on right what are you
going like those are the decisions are
we gonna make this big strategic change
in our business those are big
irreversible decisions and that's the
key for me is that if a decision is
irreversible comma and has downstream
consequences then those are the ones
that i take more time to analyze all
right now here's the here's the the
piece that i was missing in my equation
for making these decisions which i want
to share with you all right
one of the key pieces of how we decide
is the brain chemistry that is going on
so whether you have lots of dopamine
lots of serotonin that are circling
around in your brain will ultimately
affect how you make decisions believe it
or not we are 100 emotional decision
makers the thing is is what we want to
do is control the extent to which the
emotions control our decisions all right
that's the key point here if you don't
acknowledge that emotions weigh into all
of your decisions even your quote
rational ones you are lost
all right what you can do is first
identify when you are feeling emotional
and a lot of guys feel like this this is
like a a fufu turn if you're angry it's
emotional if you're insecure that's
emotional like there are other emotions
besides being a pansy if you have
emotions
it decreases
the speed with that you make decisions
and mistakes love a rushed decision you
can say it with me mistakes love a rush
decision it's one of the credos that
layla and i live by the environment
under which we make this decision is
important
now we have to acknowledge the biases
that we have here is where emotions get
even worse
you have two biases that you have to
fight against one is confirmation bias
which is
your emotional soup in your brain is
going to say this is what i want because
this is how i feel safe
then your logical brain will search out
reasons or data to support that thing
right it's like making an argument to
yourself the problem is you may change
your argument but it's not going to
change reality which means that the
decision can be good or bad based on the
soup that we started as the previous
position towards how we're going to
gather data second is conviction bias
which is
how convicted am i in this thing or this
decision the more you believe in it or
the more you want the positive outcome
to occur the more you will purposefully
blind yourself because you want to save
your ego and how you feel about yourself
because you it makes you feel good to
think about this positive outcome but it
does not affect the percentage likely
that it actually occurs in the real
world which is why you see other people
because you can be rational about others
you see other people make these terrible
decisions and you think yourself why on
god's earth would they make those
decisions when in reality that person is
you and it's other people who are
looking at you this is how i have
learned to help mitigate or decrease the
emotional impact or the impact that my
emotions have on my decision-making
process so that i can at least be as
rational as i can possibly be and
operate from the stance that will
benefit my self in the highest degree in
the long run so here's what it is number
one is that i make sure that i am well
rested when i make the decision so if i
didn't have like a really good night's
sleep like everybody knows like there's
like normal sleep there's bad sleep
there's like decent sleep but i'm
talking like you wake up like a newborn
child i recognize those days and i joke
with layla about it cause i'm like man i
slept like a like a cherub last night
like if you've got so many big decisions
i'm like let's let's make them now
because i feel completely clear all
right so number one very very good sleep
number two and this may sound [ __ ]
obvious but people don't do this right
number two is to be well fed all right
when we are well fed our serotonin
levels our dopamine levels etc all get
elevated in our body all right like you
feel better after you eat
and here's a fun one for you
your body interprets stress both
physical and emotional the same way it's
a cortisol response and so
you in a very real way when you eat more
are more stress tolerant it's why people
do it it's why people stress you because
you do
cope and make yourself more resilient to
stress when you eat more so i'm not
saying you do this all the time but if
you're going to make a big decision you
want to make sure that you are well fed
and well rested all right and what we're
doing here is we're trying to decrease
the anxieties and the stressors and the
noise that normally will confound the
decision decision-making process because
they'll start triggering emotions that
will then force you to start finding and
nitpicking different data points to then
make a supposedly rational decision that
is wrong and that it's there to protect
your ego rather than what is going to
serve you best in the long run and the
third piece of the environment that i
try and create is if i can i try and get
space away from the day-to-day
activities that i have so be that a
vacation or literally just removing
yourself from the normal space where you
operate and because those spaces have
anchors in your mind that you have made
decisions in the past you have you have
emotional occurrences that have happened
in the room or at the desk that you work
at and so you have these anchorings that
are around you and you want to remove
yourself from those things so that you
can have as few
outside influences on the decision as
you possibly can now here's the trick
is that once you ex once you create this
environment right
you want to make the decision from a
place of needing nothing
and so the definition of abundance is
having everything you need which the
corollary or the reverse of that is to
need nothing else is to have enough
and so when you have enough you will not
need this decision to get you anything
at all
and so the key to make as rational of a
decision as you possibly can is to not
care about the outcome either way and to
realize that you already have everything
you need
or want and so if you have everything
you want and you're well rested and
you're well fed and you're surrounded by
the people that you love and you realize
the things that are important in life
all of a sudden it will approach it will
help you appropriately weigh the
decision that you were trying to make
and so i don't know if anyone here who
is listening to this has an important
decision that they must make
but these are the four steps number one
rest
number two
eat
number three separate
number four
operate from a place of needing nothing
and when you have those four frames that
are stacked on top of each other they
can disinhibit
to a great degree the extent to which
your emotions will influence your
decisions they still will but
ideally secondarily so or at a at a
lower percentage of influence and so it
gives us just enough room to peak our
heads again above our emotional cloud
and make a decision that's truly
rational and when we make more rational
decisions we might we live a much easier
life all right i'll say that firsthand a
lot of the decisions i made in my past
that were based on emotions ended up
really butting me in the ass especially
when i had lots of emotions and i acted
really quickly in large ways against
irreversible decisions
great recipe for a terrible life so the
opposite of that if we're trying to use
charlie munger's inversion process is
how would i make a terrible decision i
wouldn't be real rested i'd be hungry
i would be rushed
right i'd be i'd be i'd be anchored
around all the things that stressed me
out
and i would make sure that i was
operating from place of having to have
the thing
so we look at those things and we
reverse them all
to stack in our favor so that we can
have the best possible decision and so
mostly nation
i love you all keep being awesome and
i'll see you guys in the next video bye